Hello everybody. My name is Markiplier,
and welcome back to Subnautica.
Now, you may not be able to hear it,
But if you listen closely, you can h-h-hear the screams
of hell from where we are.
Because were currently down in the Inactive Lava Zone,
Or as I, have recently discovered
"The Very Active Lava Zone with a lot of living creatures,
and a lot of horrible monstrosities." ( ͠°  ͜ʖ  ͠° )
And we're gonna get to that in just a second-
UM,
But I wanted to point out,
I'm currently running out of space for these lockers, so, *Inhales*
I know I wanted to build a locker for every single one of these,
but I actually don't have any more Titanium-
And in order to get some, I would have to go back up to the Surface,
And I'm not gonna waste you guys' time with that.
So I'm gonna read four names,
Instead of just a normal three,
So first up is Gretchin Wenther who said:
"I'm watching this to unwind and relieve stress after taking the A.C.T. today.
Love you Mark, you always help cheer me up."
So thank you so much Gretchin for watching,
I'm really glad these videos can make you a little bit happier,
After some stressful testing,
And to follow up that really nice comment, Uh-
Shortyplays1 says:
"Mark, you need to try to scan the Sea Dragon-Leviathan,
without being attacked like this so he sees this."
That is-
By n- far,
The worst idea, I have ever heard
in the history of Subnautica,
And i-if you actually want me to do that,
( T ʖ̯ T) YOU DON'T CARE ABOUT MY WELL BEING AT ALL.
But, okay..
I'll try my be-hest,
For YOUU.
Next up is Dinnerbone,
Uh- Who said:
"Mark I'm so proud of you.
Watching the series,
I have watched a "Bitchy-Baby-Boo"
develop into a less bitchy man.
Keep up the good work."
Thank you for that Dinnerbone.
Uh-I'd like to think I've replaced my-
"Bitch-Baby" nature with a more,
"Complainy-"
Type of nature,
Uh- That doesn't actually help anything while I'm down here, but
Makes me feel better. (Are you sure about that Mark?)
And last up is Galaxyghost who says:
"If you hear recurring chirping inside a powered vehicle,
That means you've probably have a Lava Larga-
Larva attached."
*Looks at the ceiling as if Macho Man is going to land an elbow drop on him*
I'm not sure if those sounds are a Lava Larga, but
It's also- *Mumbles*
Creatures that I don't wanna hear.
"The weird material in the lava zone is Kyanite.
You must've had something bugged with your game,
because you should be able to mine that."
Okay, so that's good to know-
I- I don't know what to do about it now though.
Uh- and then, three (Three?):
"Next time put a condom on Big Box Barry."
Hey,
I- I'd like to think that's not my job to
Personally do that sorta stuff,
but, I- I'll have the-
th- Sex Talks,
with Big Bocks Barry,
And uh- the responsibility he needs to take
as a father from now on.
SO-
As you can see-
Oh.
Hey.
Aww..
The weird.. creature-
I-d don't know what you are,
and I don't know why you're here-
Are my lights even on?
Oh, there we go.
Now I can't see anything still-
Okay.¯\_( ͠° ͟ʖ °͠ )_/¯
But,-
What I need to do,
before I go any further in here-
I know you guys are dying to see the Lava Dragon,
but I,
passed-
the Alien Research Lab.
I need to get to that,
because the story,
is-
paramount for this.
If I don't do that-
and I'm not entirely sure where I am
by the way.
I'm a little bit lost,
BUT,
I'm gonna try my best to turn this-
180 degrees, back round,
And to stick my ass-
back through the crevices,
that I dragged it through-
And I'm killing creatures on the way,
And just, get-
back-- OH what is thaaaaaat...?
Is that a Laaava Ray-
OOOOOOOHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH You're
BEAUTIFUL~
YOU'RE BEAUTIFUL~♪ ( ͡°з ͡°)
To me~♪? (Says Mark half-disgustingly)
Oh boy.
I don't like that at all.
With my luck,
I'm gonna run Smack-Dab into the very
center of the Dragon.
And I'm actually going deeper,
into this hellhole.
And, uh-
not at all, coming out of it.
And I never will. And I'll never see
anybody ever again.
Oh m-hey, you gonna s-
Oh~ good.
Get rekt bitch.
Okay, this seems to be generally kind of upward so,
Im'na-
I'm gonna assume that this is the way I came-
Well you know what they say about assumptions.
They lead you directly into the mouth of a
Sea Dragon-Leviathan,
That wants to eat you whole and even if-
Even if everyone tells you that it can't damage your-
Big, Giant Cyclops,-
Something tells me that's still going to try to
Eat me dead, and I'm gonna-
Be dead when I get eaten,
But not for AWHILE, but-
Until I ..pass through its digestive tract...
Then I'll be dead.
Somewhere in,
The actual-
River.
Not in the Lava Zone, but in the river,
There's another alien base
that requires this orange artifact. And
what I've been told, I haven't looked
this up to confirm this, but what I've
been told and the reason I need to find
that alien base is because I need to use
my orange artifact to get in there and
then I need to *sigh* get another artifact from
there to be able to use it to unlock the
lava zone one. So I can't progress without
it, so that's why I have to backtrack and
here is... aha
Okay this isn't the tree, but this is the
forest where the tree was, so I... I will
be back when I find it, and trust me I
know what I'm doing when it comes to
getting lost
so you can count on me being gone for
quite a--SORRY! quite a while, so I'll be
right back.
Uuuh Momma Bomba! Ah man, this still blows my mind that this is
all here
I mean I know it shouldn't, cuz' it's a
game but even so.. God, I just can't help but
imagine that there is stuff like this
hidden down in our own oceans, because
we can only map as far as radar and
sonar will allow us to see the ground
floor.
What if there's underwater under, under
the floor of the ocean; cave systems just
like this?
Miles and miles below, penetrating into
the crust of the earth, and there's just
weird, disturbing life that lives down
there.
that is a- that is a horrifying thung that I don't
want to think about it too much but it's
a possibility because we don't know... WHO
KNOWS? DOES ANYTHING KNOW? The things
that get eaten by those things know. I don't
know what's over here... it might be
something- what is that? Ooh, is that it?
What is that?
Okay-- ah! well this is something. Okay this is
definitely something
This looks like precursor, but it looks
derelict and crashed and just... kinda-- kind
of not doing so good if I had to venture
a guess
Whoa, how did I miss this? This is just
around the corner. The plateau just
before you drop down into the
braintree thing, if you take a corner
that's kind of like off to the side-- is this-
is this an entrance, noooo ─=≡Σᕕ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)ᕗthat is not
an entrance, ok. SO what are we dealing
with here? Is it- is this the thing that I
was looking for ? I'm going to assume
that it is my-- My, the gravitational pull
feels weird here
Ok, so there's got to be a way in; I think
my best bet... Is that me crashing into
something or something crashing into me?
I don't know which option I want more,
but I think this might be what I'm
looking for, because otherwise why would
be a giant precursor installation here,
as derelict as it might be?
So I'm gonna- whoa. Hey Warper buddy! Oh, ok, alright then
Well i'm gonna go down there and I'm
gonna see what I can-- what I can do
about this. Lemme just eat up before i go down
I've got my orange artifact on me and
I've got, more importantly, my Keep Calm
Kitty poster, which is definitely gonna
keep me brave and calm in the face of
sure death... which i think i'm going to
find-- Wow, things look a lot-- a lot bigger
once you're out of the Cyclops and
actually on the ground here
Whoo boy. Oh mamba jamba, what are you?
I'm just checking the sides first before
i go on the top or around the bottom, just want
to be thorough about this, and give a sweeping
search.. Some kind of skeleton down there?
Yeah, that's not- that's not machinery-- ooh
Something's not happy with me being down here...
But, that's definitely a skeleton, of some
sort, and we've got just... looks like just a...
Kind of a hole there, but not a way in
Oh, that gets trapped down here, that
must be what the shiny thing was I saw
Right! Let's get moving. Go around the sides
Yeah, it's got a lot of damage
I don't know what would have caused this
damage, besides, like, internal power
failure causing explosions and whatnot,
but.. something happened here and it's...
Whatever it is, it's not friendly
Ok. So I've looked pretty much on every side
of this thing; it doesn't seem like
there's an entrance right now, the big
docking bay that I would have guessed to
be an entrance, seems to be closed off
so, I'm just gonna assume...
*bang* Sorry about that!
Sorry, sorry -  I'm just going to assume that all
is right in the world and I move on with
my search for this thing, and this is not
what I'm looking for even though it
looks definitely like what i'm looking
for. Cause I- I checked every side of that
thing and... Whoa, wait a minute! Okay, maybe
I didn't because, holy shit, I- how did I
not see this?
What the fuck is that? What is- is that
unfinished textures?
Really? No way! How did I- how did I miss
that number one- I'm just going to go out- agh
I gotta go on the suit..
How did I miss that? Ok, I almost missed
that. I was just about ready to give up.
Holy shit, let me in there.. what the fuck-
Ok, I found... *rumbling noise*.. alright then- I found what
appears to be an unfinished area.
It's untextured... and this kind of here
What the heck is this? Is that a map? Was that what
they look like, just the interpretive art?
Ah, that's graffiti that's what it is
Whoa, just like glowing walls that- whoa,
what the frick is that? Hello? What the hell? Is that like-
is that like an aquarium in there?
Woah, the inside of this is an aquarium
What the hell... I mean I know this is
unfinished, so like, none of this has
all of its polish, but- wait that's...
This- is that an entrance to it? Should i go in there?
Oh, its some sort of medical bay?
They were studying something? Holy shit...
Where am I..? I'm literally in an
observation area inside- is this where....?
I think this is the unfinished place, where
the precursor researchers were
studying the.. the- not the sea dragon, but
the sea Emperor... unless this is where the
sea dragon was, and in its escape
destroyed the facility, which might be
totally plausible, I have no idea but..
This is so weird..
I mean I- obviously this isn't what I'm looking for, this isn't
where I use the orange artifacts because
this is unfinished, now, I know for a fact
that the, uh, the other one is part of the
main game right now, but this is still
fascinating to see--
HEY, don, no no don't come in.. Don't be ridiculous
Come on,  *mumbles* Ok.. SO that's, that's
fascinating. So that's either the place
where the sea dragon Leviathan was held
OR it's the place where the sea Emperor
will eventually be held, and that's- whoo
That is crazy cool but either way I
think I'm in the wrong place to get what
I need for this. There's a lot of
skeletons, just buried (*bang*) down there, and I can only
assume that the precursors were
exploring this area and trying to find
stuff out about the, th- the animals that
lived here and
something went wrong and they died, so
What's so fascinating is there's still
that giant skeleton, this humongous
skeleton, the enormous skeleton just
laying out in the main area, and what the
hell was that, too?
THAT is a creature that existed on this
planet, so in this world, in their
prehistoric times, if they don't even
have written history, but, before them
came enormous creatures, just enormous
creatures.. how terrifying with the
entire reality, how horrifying with all
of that, I cannot imagine, and I don't want to
imagine. I will- I will nevertheless
continue to imagine, because I can't
help myself now, because that buried in
my brain, but, hopefully.. hopefully, we
don't have to meet any of those
creatures in our lifetime... maybe
And welcome back, welcome back you may be
saying, but where are we now?
Oh... well that's different
Anyway, there are some changes now
because -- it's a good thing I actually
looked up before I spent an hour
searching like I did the last time -- uh, the
alien cache, or the precursor cache that
the orange artifact is necessary for
wasn't in the live version of the game,
it was in the experimental version. So I
saved
It's located in a place called the, the-
the Ghost Canyon, I believe it's called
I'm not a hundred percent sure- it's in the
ghost canyon, or something to that effect
I'm not a hundred percent - and you may
notice that there's some slight
differences here, one: you got the
translucent douche bags floating around
I don't mean to call you douchebag that
I'm assuming you're very nice.. very nice
perfectly normal creatures of the deep
that I don't like very much, but also, I'm
literally in a place that I just saved
and then loaded up, and I think I see it?
Yes, I do? Hi Smiley Jim- oh boy, you are
terrifying
Whoa... hey- Oh, crab squid, that's new
Oh no.. but anyway, so if you go in the
Ghost Canyon, which is the main place
that I just went to- GO AWAY!
Ohh, don't even think about it! Ya can't
affect me, my Cyclops is nigh invulnerable
Alright you do whatever you feel like
But, if you go in the ghost canyon, normally
you take a right to go down to the giant
skeleton, but in the experimental version
right here- ohh, that's loud.. right here, the
entrance to this weird creature,
apparently this, this creature right here
was strange enough that the precursor
set up an entire lab dedicated just to
studying this thing. Now, you know, they
dedicated resources to studying things
like the sea dragon Leviathan- and I am
now stuck on it which is great(!)
can I keep MOVING? Oh, why am I stuck on this?
HEY! ALL RIGHT! Let me go I got a little
further down - either way but I think
this is it.
Oh yadda yadda yadda yadda yadda
So I did- I did waste quite a bit of
time looking around for this thing, and I
apologize for that, I'm trying to do my
best here. Let me just pop out the
batteries because i need to switch-swap them
over.  Badadaboop, ba bababoop- Ooh, these are
nice and black. Charred? Have they been
burnt? (ooh boy) and this one.. Uh are we not up to full
power, is it using them spread evenly in
the experimental version?
Ooh, hello. You go there.. you go there, and we
should be up to full ish.. and I've got a
lot of- a lot of the duds here..
Okay, good enough, ok. So, now that we've got
that i'm gonna take Mr. Fister out with
me into this place, for as long as I need
to use Mr. Fister- whoo
hey, ho man.. That is weird, it's like it
reminds me of something from Starcraft
like in the Zerg things, I think from
Broodwar the thing that shot little
scared
no that was the Protoss. Ehh, I don't know my-
don't know my Starcraft anymore because
*mumbles* Ok, so this should
be the terminal, and that means I'm
gonna save, I'm saving the
experimental version which might ruin
my save entirely, I haven't backed it up but
I'm committed to continuing in the
experimental mode because is where all
the crazy stuff can happen but i'm going
to save, because, boy howdy, am I weird.. right
bop that bad boy down in there, oh yeah
I'm almost wasting all of my time
Alright open up for me- Ooh.. whaat's thiiis...? Whoogh...
What dramatic music you seem to be playing for some
strange reason
Ohh ok... (eugh, alrighty then) So there's some kind of bony alien
own specimen case- ohh, that sounds
horrifying.. Oh yeah I'll get a good read
of that one
Ohh... so they were just as curious as i was
about these bones going to davis I'd
actually taking with them and then the
ghost of the horrible monstrosity
followed them and murdered them all.. Ok, these
fossils likely came from an ancient
ancestor of the Leviathans which inhabit
the planet today
HEY! That's- that's actually exactly what
I guessed,  isn't it?
I'd like to think so anyway, ok oh its that
weird map thing again, okay
Fauna Reproductive Data - Mmm, I bet that's
an enticing read. Ok, this terminal
contains extensive data on the
reproductive methods of the local fauna
found on the planet evolved with a
single gender capable of both egg laying
and insemination. Eggs once laid usually
require genetic material from a second
individual to reach maturity. In rare
cases there is only one true parent, with
evolutionary mutation introduced by the
effects of the environment itself on the
delicate genetic structure of the child
Research appears to have been focused
around hatching conditions and genetic
variations between parent and child
this is consistent with the theory that
the aliens were invested in manipulating
the life cycle of the local species to
their ends
Why though? Why though? Why did they do
this? Why? I mean there's a lot of
questions like for research that we
humans do it was like, I don't know
because we felt like it,
I don't know, because we were bored, I don't know
because we want to dabble with powers
beyond our control
You know, something along those lines
Man, this is just weird
All this stuff.. oh really, research
equipment, hell yeah. I want to know about
the probing table, that'd be nice, and I need to
get the data
yes you're right... ooh... Okay all right then I'm
gonna.. I'm gonna assume that that means
well
Ok, "These local flora are being held in stasis.
The aliens evidently sought an extensive
knowledge of the planet's ecosystem. The large
laboratory table and accompanying
scanners incorporate technologies far
beyond our current level of
understanding. Hypothesis: equipment
maintenance; staff maintenance; specimen
analysis; speen- specimen gene
manipulation" What are- These alien sure
did like their genetic manipulation,
which is awfully nice of them. can they
do some manipulation on me to make me
not so terrified of everything down here?
That'd be nice
Excuse me. Abduct me, please. Mother ship- oh..
Sorry I only got the wrong hole
Bedeboop- oh that guy's definitely, ooh that
guy's all kind of uh, -???- so
anyway, now that I'm in the
experimental mode I can actually do
something that a lot of people were
recommending me but I couldn't do which
was to scan myself. *text onscreen*
*text onscreen*
Okay... so if i take my glove off now, what am I
going to see? *bang* What bumped up against me?
No, nothing so far. I am infected though, so
that's good to know
Greeaaat. I'm super infected, whoopdi doowhoopdidoo-
But, anyway we found that, so unlike what I
assumed, we did not get another key but
now that we're in the experimental mode
we should see a lot more changes
progressing more quickly as we go down
into the deep. Alright, so we finally
found out- we discovered some
interesting things about these creatures,
and this is indeed a prehistoric remnant
of the Leviathan species
I'm really happy
*mumbles*  I'm
really happy that those big ones aren't
around anymore, but knowing the
precursors, were they trying to resurrect
that lost species for their own ends?
Were they trying to use something about
them, to benefit their species in
general? An- and it's weird that they would
considering the precursors are such an
obviously technologically advanced
species
Why would they need to? They're able to
genetically manipulate pretty much
anything including their own species so
why would they need to? But, sadly, I am
actually all out of time- taking a big
dip over here-
I know it seems like I'm just not
showing you guys everything that I intend to
but I've made a promise that I was
going to go through this
this time i was playing through again
calmly and collectively and we keep
discovering amazing new things and I
love every second of that, because every
single time I go into this game, I'm
surprised - every single thing I meet, I'm
surprised - and I love that feeling of
surprise, I do, I love it- I love knowing
that around every single corner is
something new and horrifying that I
haven't discovered yet, and yet, I keep
plowing forward despite my brain telling me
not to! So, it's still fun, and I hope you
guys are enjoying it too. I'll get that
back down to be inactive lava zone and
hopefully, the Kyanite will actually work,
and then I can utilize that in addition
to the other materials that are down
there, to hopefully upgrade my, my Mr.
Fister, who's going to take me down to the
very deepest parts of the Inactive Lava Zone
We'll get there soon
So, thank you everybody so much for
watching, and as always, I will see you in the
next video. Buh-Bye!!